Over the course this lesson, we discover a super powerful tool because of
Grant's airplane situation. We can now find the distance between any two points
on a graph. And, I don't just mean points that we can count squares on graph
paper to find the distance between. I mean, any two points on a coordinate
plane. Think about how you used triangles, right triangles in particular, to
find the distance from Grant's hometown to the city Udacity. Can you do
something similar to find the distances between these points on this graph? To
make your life easier, I only want you to find the distance from A to B, from B
to C, from C to D and from D to A. Please write your answers in exact form. In
other words, I don't want you to round. Instead, I would like you to write them
in whatever form you need to write them to represent the actual exact number
that each length is equal to. To help you do this, I'd like to remind you that
if you want to enter a square root sign, using MathQuill, you need to type the
keys back \sqrt, and then the space bar. Then, you can use your arrow keys to
move your cursor around.